German storm chaser antica belling and
his friends traveled to the United
States regularly to observe extreme
weather phenomena like tornadoes it's
their hobby they come equipped with
cameras and tripods their trophies are
spectacular pictures ten years ago
Germany storm chasers got together and
founded an association called a sky
woman an important resource for them is
dependable radar data confidently we get
it from the meteorological services in
particular from Germany's weather
service doppler radar data tells us
where precipitation is falling in
Germany at the time in deutschland
failed the derivative here the storm
chasers determined that the situation
looks dangerous with massive
precipitation that might include hail
they say it's time to head out the storm
chasers of skywarn are to experience
nature of the first hand and while
they're at it they're supplying vital
information for storm warnings diadochi
vetted in turn on the german and other
meteorological services get measurements
from remote sensing satellites doppler
radar and gauging stations but they
themselves can't see what's going on and
that's where the skywarn spotter is come
in we describe ourselves as the eye of
the storm we can look at the storm cell
and see what's happening that we can see
hail falling or a funnel cloud
developing and watch it touch the ground
and wreak destruction instruments can't
do that as fast and pass the information
on to weather services limited now look
here that looks dangerous to be on the
safe side we ought to make a report you
can see the sheets of hail falling and
they're heading straight for us fun on
taking all of them sue
they report hailstones two centimeters
thick to the German meteorological
service this time the storm chasers send
out a warning and the weather service
sends the warning on to the public of
ones and carve our workstation graphic
instruments show activity right on the
spot where the sky Warner made that
report this kind of eyewitness report by
trained observers like the sky Warner's
help us find out the details with hail
for example how big are the hailstones
is there already a ground cover our
other data don't show us things like
that and we can't see tornadoes at all
on our doors dicamba bogna see germany
has 40 to 60 tornadoes per year the US
has up to a thousand many casualties
here are avoided thanks to warnings from
the volunteer weather observers America
is not in America of course the
potential danger is much greater there's
the tornado alley in and around Oklahoma
and it's really a matter of saving human
lives eighty sky warner's are active in
Germany extreme weather is their hobby a
hobby the weather services can use to
good effect
you